- In a previous video
we talked about trying
to estimate a population
mean with a sample mean
and then constructing
a confidence interval
about that sample mean.
And we talked about different scenarios.
We could use a Z table plus the true
population standard deviation,
and that actually would construct
pretty valid confidence intervals,
but the problem is you don't know
the population standard deviation.
And so you might try to us a Z table
to find your critical values
plus the sample standard deviation,
but what we talked about
is this doesn't actually
do a good job of calculating
our confidence intervals,
and we're gonna see that
experimentally in a few seconds.
And so instead we have
something called a t-statistic
where if we want our critical
value we use a t-table
instead of a z-table.
And then we use that in conjunction
with our sample standard deviation,
and then all of a sudden
we are actually going
to have pretty good confidence intervals.
To make this a little bit more real,
let's look at a simulation.
So this is a scratch pad on Khan Academy,
made by Khan Academy user Charlotte Allen.
And the whole point there is to see what
our confidence intervals look like
with these different scenarios.
So let's say we have a true
population mean of 2.0,
let's say it the average number,
the mean number of
apples people eat a day.
The true population mean
is two, that seems high,
but maybe it's in a certain country
that has a lot of apples.
And let's say that we
know that the population
standard deviation is 0.5.
And we're going to create
confidence intervals with
a goal of having a 95
percent confidence level,
and we're gonna take sample sizes of 12.
So first, we can construct
our confidence intervals
using z and sigma, which is
a legitimate way to do it.
And so let's just draw
a bunch of samples here.
And so we do see that it looks like
it is roughly 95 percent.
When we keep making these
samples, and constructing
these confidence
intervals, that 95 percent
of the time these confidence
intervals contain our
true population mean.
So these look like a good
confidence intervals,
but what we've talked
about is normally when your
doing this type of thing,
this type of inferential statistics,
you don't know the population
standard deviation.
You don't know sigma. So
instead, you might be tempted to
use z with our sample standard deviations.
But if you look at that for
these exact same samples
we just calculated,
notice, now when we did it
over and over again,
we've done this 625 times,
in this scenario, where
we keep calculating the
confidence intervals with z
and s, the true population
mean is contained in the intervals
only 92.2 percent of the the time.
Now we could keep going.
So we have a much lower
hit rate than we would
hope to have if we were
actually using z and sigma.
Now what's neat is, if
we use t, use a t-table,
notice, this is getting much
closer, and this is neat!
Because with a t-table, and
something we can actually
get from the sample, the
sample standard deviation,
we're actually able to have a pretty close
hit rate to what we would have
if we actually knew the
population standard deviation.
So that's the value of t and t-statistics,
and we're going to give
more and more examples,
including using a
t-table in future videos.